all right hello everybody my name is
Eric Williams and today I'll share you
some insights on how to select the right
tools to build your pure puddin based
disease model through genome editing
so before
I go into detail that I kind of wanted
to align on what a cell model is and and
how we are now able to use in vitro
approaches to predict human biology so
with the discovery of pluripotent stem
cells we can now easily generate a
variety of different cell types from a
human being and use those cells to model
human biology in in vitro so when you
think about human biology there's in the
human being there are several inputs
you know there's genetics there's the
environment there's nutrition there's
different drugs and all those different
inputs has have an effect on on how we
feel
you know they present different symptoms
their different biomarkers in our blood
that appear and you know there's variety
of outcomes depending on what that input
is and so really the challenge to
understand human biology is it's very
difficult to experiment in the human
body and we can now go in vitro thanks
to the stem cells and build some of
these models in vitro and when you think
about the different inputs in an in
vitro system we can try and mimic some
of the inputs in the human body by over
expressing genes knocking them down
knocking them out we can use different
media systems to alter the physiology of
cells we can expose them to different
drugs so that we can look for phenotypic
response in themselves and you know the
outputs then they're not very new it's
gene expression protein function so
health and any kind of cell phenotype
that you think about and so really the
goal here is that we cannot build these
in feature cell models to predict
outputs in vitro and then hopefully some
of these can be translated into an
organism
such as the human and you know this
whole idea is very important when we
drink think about a drug development
pipeline where in vitro assays are being
performed first to screen for drug
candidates which are then prioritized
for clinical trials
so when you think about building an
airport and stem cell-based disease
modeling model tool
there's an entire workflow where you
start with the donor and then you can
take that donor reprogram the donor into
pluripotent stem cells and you can
culture these cells you can characterize
them if you wanted to you can do some
genomic engineering in them you can then
differentiate them into the cell type
that you're interested in for example
you could turn them into a neuron and
then using those neurons you could then
run a variety of a space to measure the
different phenotypes and so kind of what
I wanted to highlight is that thermo
Fisher here and that entire workflow
provides a lot of the reagents to do
that entire workflow in your lab and at
the same time we also provide services
to do this and but really I'm not going
to spend too much time about what thermo
Fisher has to offer and rather spend
time about the tools and how to make
disease modeling a lot easier so when
you think about disease modeling genome
editing is really taken the forefront of
disease modeling as it now allows us to
easily generate isogenic disease models
so before you know meditating was
available people with
use learn ourselves from a healthy donor
and they would use donor cells from a
diseased donor and then it would compare
these different cell lines but the main
issue there is that they were not really
accounting for the value variability
between two different human beings
outside of the disease state and so what
we cannot do with genome editing is we
can for example take a healthy donor use
genome editing to introduce mutations
that are associated with disease and
then you have a isogenic pair of cell
lines with the same genetic background
and you can then use those cells
differentiate them and run the acid on
the other side you could take a diseased
donor and then use genome editing to
correct some of these disease-causing
mutations and again have a nicer genic
pair that you could use for modeling the
disease the back in 2013 at thermo
Fisher we tried to build some of these
these models and collaborations at the
Parkinson's Institute and the idea was
to revert disease or Parkinson's disease
causing mutations back to control and in
the table in the left bottom on the
slide you can see some of these
mutations that we looked at and then we
took fibroblasts from those patients
generated IPSC from them expanded the
IPS see using the media tools that were
available back then
and use the talent based approach to try
and revert these single base mutations
that were causing the disease and after
we then succeeded in a genome
engineering we then differentiated
themselves and looked for phenotypes
now while in the end we succeeded in
this whole plan it took us about two
years to get from start to finish and we
really identified a number of challenges
in the whole genome engineering workflow
so for for example first of all we were
using talons which were on a plasmid and
and they were larger donor DNA and
larger donor DNA is hard to deliver to
cells
lipid based methods were not working you
know the genomic cleavage as a result of
that and genome editing efficiency was
very low because delivery wasn't working
very well and and so the media systems
were not really supporting efficient
delivery but then in addition the after
we then were able to deliver the genome
editing tools to the cells the media
systems did not allow us to reliably
isolate single cell clones we have to do
it manually cut out clones and put one
piece in in a tube to test the genomic
modifications and then the other piece
would go back into a plate and expand
and you know doing that obviously that
resulted in having mixed populations
because we weren't sure that these
colonies were emerging from one cell or
multiple cells and so there were
multiple runs of screening and clone
isolation required
really making this a lengthy and and
iterative process that was really a
bottleneck in the entire genome editing
workflow so over the years thermo Fisher
worked on a lot of innovations to
improve improve the genome editing
efficiency as as itself and then at the
same time we worked on building products
that allowed more efficient clonal
isolation as well as the downstream
disease modeling and so I'll sort of
talk through how we've been playing
around with these different tools and
how we then use them into building these
models and other applications and for
stem-cell research
so when you think about the different
tools that are available for genome
editing and you know obviously with the
emergence of CRISPR things have changed
dramatically being CRISPR being a much
more simple tool to do the genome
editing and so we are now already at our
second generation of a cassadine protein
so it's a protein that yields high
cleavage in and homology driven repair
target dependently you can complex it
with guide RNAs and it can be delivered
with either like electroporation or ly
perfection based methods and you know in
addition to that we also reoptimize the
talent system and rather than having a
large DNA vector we now have the sounds
available as mRNAs and can be easily
delivered using again the same
electroporation or LipPerfection
conditions and then a third tool that we
worked on with making a stable cast 9ip
se line where the cell line expresses
the cast nine and then you simply
deliver the guide RNA and the donors and
you can then do the genome editing that
way and again you can use different
delivery methods for the tools here
so speaking about delivery tools the two
main tools that work very well for
delivering crisper cast nine tools as
well as talents is a type effect amine
reagent that was specifically developed
for stem cells so it allows for delivery
of DNA RNA and cast 9 and guide RNA
protein complexes no it doesn't affect
the cells in any way so there there's no
cell death in these conditions and you
can do the transaction either on
adherent cells or using a reverse
transaction where you would do the
transaction as you beat cells on a new
plate on the other hand we have our
Niang transaction system which is
another electroporation based method
this method does provides superior
transfection and editing in stem cells
compared to ly perfection based method
you can do knock out knock in with with
the tool and then there's a number of
different parameters that you can test
out so you can you can really optimize
the system to get delivery parameters
that give you high genome editing
efficiency and at the same time give you
high cell viability
so just to sort of give you a sense of
what it looks like with using the
different tools on the left-hand side
when you consider the different cast
nine options that we have so I mentioned
this table cast nine IPs see that we
have and then I also mentioned our
second generation through cast night
protein and then comparing that to our
first generation cast nine protein you
can clearly see on the left hand side
that the second generation cast nine
protein in red and the stable cast nine
line pretty much work on par in terms of
the efficiency of introducing snips in
the different genes listed here on the
left hand side where as the first
generation cast nine protein while it
was working very well in a variety of
cancer cell lines it was not really
working well for pluripotent stem cells
so that definitely that second
generation protein dramatically
increased their efficiency for genome
editing in stem cells
so then when you think about delivery
and in this case we're delivering the
second generation protein complexed with
with the guide RNA and then small
hundred base single-stranded donors to
introduce snips in the different genes
and so what you can clearly see in in
the blue bars on the right hand side
graph is that the neon electroporation
system provides superior genome editing
efficiency across all targets in the two
cell lines that are shown here compared
to the life effect amines summary agents
shown in yellow what I do like to point
out too is that while the neon looks far
superior the life effect amines them
does yield high enough editing
efficiency that allow that would allow
you to isolate single cell clones and so
it's really a decision of what is
available to you and what are you most
comfortable working with
aside from picking the delivery tools
and the genome editing tool the media
system that you use is also important
when you're especially when you're using
electroporation I sort of mentioned that
electroporation tends to be a little bit
more stressful on the self compared to
lie perfection however when you use
proper media conditions that is not so
much of an issue so in this graph shown
here is that when you're electroplating
cells either with delivery of a guide
RNA shown in red or in the absence of a
guide RNA that
when you look at the recovery 48 hours
after
electroporation the media system alone
has a pretty dramatic impact in the
overall recovery of the cells as you can
see essential aid and our newer stem
flex medium outperform some of the other
competitors that are out there and
really provide you much quicker recovery
post electroporation which again you
know helps you to increase your time
lines when you're thinking about doing a
genome editing in purpose themselves so
putting putting these sort of
explorations about which tools are the
best we then went ahead and built some
genome editing platform for introducing
a large number of these model mutations
and in this graph there's about ten or
so looking at different diseases in
cardiomyocytes neurons dopaminergic
neurons and we basically use the
Cassadine IPSC line delivering guide
RNAs and single stranded all egos to
look at genome editing and then we
either use the genomic cleavage
detection method to look at endo
formation and we use targeted
next-generation sequencing to introduce
or to look at the introduction
efficiency of snips what you can see is
that even though that the editing
efficiency both for indels and snips is
is largely different between a different
targets we do succeed to get at least 5%
of the self edited with the desired
change
so that the next challenge after having
these pools with with edits is now how
do I get my clone online and so then we
really spend a lot of time in optimizing
protocols to be able to use single cell
sorting as a way to very efficiently
isolate single sub cones from
pluripotent stem cell pools that have
been edited so we use a very stringent
sorting protocol where you know we use
different two different scatter gates to
make sure that we're isolating single
cells and in addition to that we use
propidium iodide negative cells to make
sure that these are viable cells and
then we also use trauma sixty positive
cells to make sure that the cells that
we are depositing are pluripotent and so
with a cell sorter you can then deposit
a single pluripotent viable cell into a
well of a 96-well plate and you can then
fill up large numbers of 96-well plates
to generate your single cell clones and
so what we then try to do is that
because with the media systems that were
available five years ago it really
wasn't possible to do this so we spent a
lot of time on evaluating post sort
components of looking at different cell
substrates looking at different media
looking at different supplements to the
media and you know this slide here is
giving a bit of a summary on that
indicating that you know when you were
using essential eight in gel tricks or
maître gel which is very similar we
really weren't getting many clones to
survive however when you started dialing
in revita cell which is a supplement
that helps survival of single
pluripotent stem cells and and use lemon
in five to one as a matrix we started to
see that the cloning efficiency was
going up a little bit and then when you
change the medium to stem flicks that
cloning efficiency was even much higher
and as you can see on the right hand
side the clones that you get they have
difficult or potent stem cell morphology
and they are staining for their potent
markers such as dry 160 so using this
protocol has really removed the whole
manual picking process from from the
workflow and you can go from edited pool
to single cell clones in a quick at
twelve twelve days so this this alone
has really dramatically shortened the
timeline of the genome editing workflow
so we then wanted to take it a step
further and put put some of these
disease relevant pools that we generated
put them through the test with that
single cell sorting system so we isolate
single cell clones from all these
different mutants and then took them
further and look at disease phenotypes
so you just sort of highlight you in
this slide is that the editing
efficiency in the pool was very
different for the different targets and
so what you see in the five charts here
is the representation of the different
clones that we identified after
screening so you know how many
homozygous
snips did we find how many heterozygous
snip quizzes refine how many clones have
an endo and how many clones were
unedited so you can clearly see that
this is very different between the
different targets some extent related to
the overall editing efficiency in the
pool
and so what we then did for all of these
but I'm just going to talk about one
example today so we basically
differentiated these cells and then turn
them into cell types of interest and
looked at acids so the one I'm talking
about today is a lark - G - a 19's
mutation which is the model for
Parkinson's disease and using all the
tools that I talked about and before we
actually did the differentiation we did
a thorough characterization of the cells
we looked at at our scorecard panel
which is basically a Q PCR based method
to ensure that the cells are pluripotent
to reassure ourselves that the cells are
pluripotent we also run a flurry test as
they which is a microarray based system
to validate the souther pluripotent and
we did sequence sequence conformation of
course we wanted to make sure that the
cells that we had have the correct
mutation in the DNA and at the same time
we also did amplified or targeted
amplified next-generation sequence
confirmation so that we could look at
ten thousands of reads to ensure that
the cell line was clonal
and then we also did a whole genome
genomic stability essay using the
carousel assay which is basically a
digital karyotyping of the self and
after all the genome editing
manipulations and the single cell
cloning manipulations that we've done
under cells we did not notice any
changes on the side so that gave us
confidence that we could move this line
forward for differentiation and assays
on stream
so you know we turned ourselves into
dopaminergic neurons and here is the
immunostaining comparison between the
parental line and then the disease line
and we saw a clear expression of
neuronal markers so beta tubulin was
expressed nicely and
tyrosine hydroxylase which is a marker
specifically for dopaminergic neurons
was also well expressed in these
cultures so we then ran a number of
assays to see whether we could detect
any differences between them the healthy
and the diseased neurons and one thing
we looked at wasn't a right outgrowth
and as you can see in the plot on the
left hand side which is basically
tracking the right length over time we
observed to two distinct patterns there
in in the red box and this is when the
neurons are growing out of the neuronal
cell body we notice that the large two
mutants had a significant delay in the
outgrowth of the neurons compared to the
wild type control or some of the other
diseases lines that we looked at however
when we looked at the later stages when
the neurites were fully outgrown and the
lengths are stabilized we noticed that
the larger neurons have larger or longer
neurites compared to the control stages
whereas some other disease and actually
had short turnaround compared to the
control lines this is just clearly
showing that you know by introducing a
single base change through genome
editing that you could see phenotypic
differences in neurons but to reassure
ourselves that we were really looking at
a relevant phenotype we we looked at the
sensitivity to six hydroxy dopa which is
a toxin specifically for dopaminergic
neurons when parkinson's neurons are
known to be more sensitive to cell death
so we use an apoptotic assay here that
lights up green when the cells are going
into apoptosis and you can see on the
left hand side panel there in DMSO
conditions you have a few green cells
but the majority are blue from the
nuclear dye where as you add star
aspirin which is a general toxic reagent
or six hit drugs
that you get an increased signal of the
green indicating more apoptosis is
occurring so we then looked at that in
the context of different disease lines
and under normal glucose conditions you
can already see that under challenge
with six drug siddhappa that the lark to
mutant is much more sensitive to
apoptosis compared to the wild type
lines and some of the other disease
lines however when you then remove
glucose and put more stress on the cells
pretty much all our two mutant cells are
now dying and also some of the other
mutants that we've developed were
showing a sensitivity through the six
addressed OPA
so this is clearly showing you that we
can in vitro model a phenotype that have
been known from Parkinson's patients in
vivo and these kind of assays can then
be used to
30 drugs that would help ameliorate the
phenotype we also looked at qpcr some
some of these disease specific mutations
caused very specific downstream gene
activation and so what you're seeing
here is that the genes that we show are
specifically up regulated by the g20
19's mutation in large - and you can see
that in yellow compared to the blue that
all these genes are upregulated in ours
in our system compared to a wild-type
cell line however when you look at those
same genes in other Parkinson's related
mutants these genes are not not up
regulated indicating that indeed we are
able to see these mark 2 g2a 19's
specific gene changes
so to summarize this first part is that
you know generating a disease model it's
all about the tools that you use if you
use the proper genome editing tools
ahead of time
you'll get higher editing efficiency
which then sets you up for success in
the cool isolation peace with clonal
isolation if you use media that are best
for single cell survival such as ourself
legs medium you can make your life a lot
easier for the kkona isolation part and
then you know if you have all the right
tools to differentiate yourself and run
the assays on the on the cells at the
back end it's really a great advance in
getting your disease model built and
working in no time so you know sort of
the innovations that thermo Fisher has
that I talked about really help you
introducing the effort and cycle time
when you generate those disease models I
quickly also wanted to spend a few
minutes on on how these same sort of
tools and reagents are also relevant
when you think about using accuracy in
clinical research you know most of the
tools that we have available today are
for research use only but we are
actively working on getting most of
these products available also as a CTS
branded product so that you can use
these same products when you're building
cells or therapeutics and I briefly
wanted to highlight some of the other
things that we've done and where stuff
like medium has really played an
important role is that we've done a
large project where we we wanted to
understand the value ability between
different donors and how that affects
the IPS see that comes out of it and how
that would affect a downstream
product that is derived from the IPSC
and so what we did is we took a large
number of donors reprogrammed them all
using our site attune 2.0 ka and then
use stamps likes to really propagate
those cells and we monitored the potency
and then we differentiated all those
cells using an embryo body method to
look at trial lineage bias
and and you know we succeeded in this
very easily just because the and the
robustness of the reagents and then the
sort of and with a little story that's
somewhat related to disease modeling but
is yet more relevant to to the clinical
approach is that we worked with a
customer where they wanted to make
pluripotent stem cells that were evasive
to the immune system so that they could
differentiate those we're putting stem
cells into a variety of differentiated
progeny that they could then use to as a
cell therapy or you know treating tissue
loss or that or if you have that much
different tissue that needs to be
replaced
so their idea was that if they if they
knocked out some of the proteins that
are causing in a human immune response
they could then make the cells immune
evasive so using the tools that I talked
about
we basically first knocked out some of
these proteins that are relevant for
immune evasive Ness and then at the same
time we overexpress the number of genes
using a lentiviral based approach to in
the end come up with one to a potent
stem cell line that would be completely
in stealth mode for the immune system
and and our customers then
differentiated that in two different
cell types such as cardiomyocytes and
endothelial cells and injected those
cells into mice and what you can see in
the left hand slides here or in the left
hand side of the slide is that when you
use differentiated wires ourselves after
a couple weeks those cells are
completely removed by the immune system
of immunized or you know humanized mice
whereas if you use the differentiate
itself from the immune evasive IPS see
you can see that the signal in those
models is sustained well beyond 40 and
50 days indicating that this genome
engineering really enabled the immune
evasive Ness of the system and what I'd
like to point out here is that you know
thanks to the tail the the tools that we
have here we really enable this customer
to get this genome engineered cell lines
in their hands very quickly and you know
it enabled them to publish that work in
nature biotechnology
and with that I will end the
presentation and I'm happy to answer any
questions that you may have
thank you dr. Willems for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of our
webinar if you have a question you would
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we will
answer as many questions as we have time
for ok let's get started
dr. Williams did you determine what the
mechanism for cell recovery was for
different mediums
that is an interesting question you know
in terms of stocking what the mechanism
is for recovery it's not entirely sure
to me what the exact mechanism is but
when you're looking at the different
media it's just the way the way they
were built and what they were built for
so when you think about essential aid
it's a very lean medium that has the
minimal factors to maintain pluripotent
stem cells in their pluripotent state
whereas when you think about stem flick
we built that medium from the ground up
to understand what components are
important for single cell survival so we
basically took a screening approach
where from hundreds of different
components that a medium can contain we
screened a large number of them to
understand which one would be more
beneficial for single cell survival and
you know so when you think about picking
a different media you should really be
considerate considering what the
application is if you have a lot of
single cells messaging or single cell
isolation as required it's really
beneficial to pick a medium that is
optimized for single cell survival
compared to working working with the
traditional sense of media like
essential later and teaser
Thank You dr. Williams now let's go with
this one it come in a few times how do I
choose the best genome editing tools for
my workflow
okay so the way to choose your genome
editing tools you know there there's a
number of decisions there when you talk
about the editing tools themselves
you either have thousands of or CRISPR
of course you know the fur the first big
big choice of course is do I use talent
or CRISPR based on the ethical landscape
as some of you may be aware there is
still some some legal disputes going on
around the CRISPR Hill intellectual
property and so some of our customers
are hesitant to use crispers because
they don't know what what downstream
royalties are going to be that they
would have to pay and they will choose
talent so that that would one be one
decision making a second piece for
decision making is that crispers they
require a unique code in the genome and
so it's a three base requirement that a
CRISPR needs to be able to cut and those
three base requirements are not not
available in the entire genome so even
though CRISPR is a more efficient
editing tool that three Bay's
requirement is at the same time a
limitation because now you cannot
position the CRISPR wherever you want in
the genome and that's where talent would
come in because you can position them
anywhere and you can position them on
exactly the base where you want to cut
your DNA and I'll elaborate a little bit
further on this question because it's
not not just about the editing tools
themselves you know it's also about how
you deliver them and and then and what
forms of the tool that you use so so
when you think about talyn's mrna
delivery is much easier compared to DNA
delivery when you think about delivery
crisper cast 9 we found that delivering
the gas 9 proteins actual protein
another DNA or mRNA that encodes the
kasnian protein actually allows much
more efficient genome editing so they're
the type of tool within CRISPR or within
talent has a big impact on how efficient
it is and then
you know in addition how do you deliver
them I sort of mentioned it during my
presentation we find that neon
electroporation in general is much more
efficient in terms of delivery even
though there's a small impact on uhm so
cell viability the overall editing
efficiency in the pool that you obtain
is much higher compared to ly
perfections based methods
and how deep is that that
thank you dr. mom okay what is the
difference in stem flex medium compared
to other media I sort of alluded to that
question already
so really you know stem flex was built
as I said it was built from the ground
up to support single cell survival
there's a number of components in a
media that promote single cell survival
and you know at the same time the growth
factors that are in there are stabilized
so that you'd have you don't have to do
daily media changes and you know that
also allows you to actually do weekend
free culture where you can basically
feed yourself on a Friday and let the
cell go over the weekend without having
to come in on the weekend and you know
really saving you some of your weekend
back
Thank You dr. William so we have so many
great questions coming in and I want to
remind our audience that those questions
we do not have time for today and those
submitted during our on-demand period
will be addressed by dr. Willam via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration now we have claim
for a few more what are the advantages
of using a caste 9 protein / plasmid
okay so um you know it
mentioned again it's how you you choose
your tools when you deliver the plasmid
the plasmid is not going to go in every
cell and then in every cell that the
plasmid goes into you're never
guaranteed that the plasmid is going to
yield enough protein to our efficient
genome engineering so if you directly
deliver the protein and you can pre
complex the protein with the guide RNA
before you put it in the cells you
actually deliver that straight to the
cells and you can you know you can
really target a lot more cells with the
protein and so your overall editing
efficiency in your pool is going to go
up because you can reach a lot more
cells with the protein complex with the
guide RNA
if I don't have an electric orator how
do you recommend to move forward
so if you don't have an electric razor
such as a knee such as our neon system
there's a couple ways that you could
move forward so one way is to use our
life effect means them reagent as I
mentioned it's not the most efficient
for genome editing efficiency but we
have found that for a lot of the targets
the editing efficiency is high enough to
reach to be able to isolate clones
another thing that I'll mention there is
that you know we do provide a demo kit
for genome editing that would allow you
to basically bring in all the key
reagents that you need for a successful
edit and that demo kit is available and
paired with a demo instrument for the
neon the one option that you have there
is that you could work with your local
sales representatives to bring in that
kit and the demo unit into your lab and
then do the genome engineering with with
those reagents and tools
and then you know if you liked it you
could and you're considering us doing a
lot more genome editing you could at
least test it out and then consider
purchasing an eon if you're only having
to do one or two genome edits you could
basically rely on us to provide your
demo instrument to help you succeed in
your genome editing workflow
and we'll end with this final question
are there any advantages of expanding
spells and stem flex compared to other
media systems such as essential 8
um yes there there's definitely a number
of advantages one is that you can you
can passage stem cells even as a single
cell level in stem flex without using
Rock inhibitors or refine a self
supplement for example so that is one
advantage the other advance the other
advantages I sort of alluded to a little
bit so you know you don't have to do
daily feed you can keep weekend you can
enable single cell sorting which with
essential aids is much more a lot more
challenging and so that there's really a
lot a lot of benefits of of stem flex
and you know on all the extensive
evaluation that we've done while the
product was developed but also
afterwards in all the applications that
we've used it for and the disease
modeling and the different cell models
that we made this medium is really
robust it allows the stuff to be
maintained their pluripotency and
genomic stability which is not something
that we always see with with essential
aid and then a last thing that I'll call
out is the fact that for finicky
pluripotent stem cell lines we've seen
that stem flexes is really outperforming
essential aide and that we see that cell
lines that we're going to be finicky
essential aid or empties or for that
matter can be grown really easily in
stem flex without showing any excessive
differentiation in the culture
thank you again dr. Williams now do you
have a any final comments for our
audience you know basically ends with
saying that if you want to make a
disease model and you have any
challenges feel free to reach out to us
or your local sales representative and
we can help you out either with
providing you the right reagents of
protocols or even helping out with the
service to do some of this work for you
thank you again now before we go I would
like to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions as a reminder those questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by dr. Williams via
the contact information you provided at
time of registration additionally this
presentation is educational and it does
offer continuing education credits
please click on that continuing
education credits tab located at the top
of your screen and follow the process to
obtain your credit once again we'd like
to thank dr. Eric Williams first time
today and for his valuable insight on
selecting the right tools to build our
pluripotent stem cell based disease
models thank you again to labyrinth and
also our sponsor Thermo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on Japan's and labret swil alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and we hope to see you again soon have a
great day